monsieur à grimaldi merci d'être avec
nous en direct alors cette prime cowitz
est pas vraiment clair et qui touche à
quoi on ne sait pas vraiment en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est 1500 euros ce n'est
pas tout le monde qui va les percevoir
oui mais à la fois pour ce qu'ils
perçoivent ce n'est pas une vie jab et
en même temps c'est pas la demande
première vue oui monsieur comédie alors
si on lit entre les lignes
ça veut dire quoi précisément que
certains soignants serait en tout cas
moi méritons qu'à d'autres
oui parce que si je peux terminer ce que
demandent les soignants c'est pas une
prime pour une action exceptionnelle
reconnu mais c'est une reconnaissance de
leur métier
la reconnaissance du métier la france
pour ce qu'elle fait a besoin sa mère et
en 28e position sur 32 pays ocde et les
infirmières les soignants de peuvent
d'ailleurs travaillé que si l'ensemble
du personnel administratif et logistique
est à leur service donc c'est l'ensemble
des personnels de l'hôpital et les
hospitaliers du sud sont venus prêter
main forte aux hospitaliers qui était à
l'aise ceodore qu'ils étaient submergés
par la crise donc ce qu'on dise que
demande le personnel depuis longtemps
c'est une augmentation du salaire et les
personnels des urgences demandé 300
euros par mois
si on voulait mettre le niveau la
famille et en france au niveau moyen le
cpe ses 450 euros donc le gouvernement
s'est rendu compte que ni la prime ni
encore moins la médaille ne pouvait
correspondre aux demandes des personnels
autrement il faut savoir qu'avant la
crise il manquait à la famille aux
hôpitaux de paris sans ce public au
total 800 postes non pourvus les gens
partiront si leur métier n'est pas
reconnu
donc la prime d'une part comme vous
l'avez dit elle est sélective elle
risque même d'être un peu sont les
personnels ceux qui sont pas directement
contacter ceux qui sont directement
contacté ce que le brancardier que ce
vaccin
et puis d'autre part c'est pas là
alors le gravant depuis a dit qu'il va
le faire mais il ya eu tellement de
déclarations tellement de promesses
depuis tellement longtemps que les gens
se demandaient ce que cette fois ci sa
femme réelle ou à ce que dès septembre
on dira ya d'autres priorités il ya le
chômage que ça auquel cas on risque de
voir des gens à nouveau quitter les
hôpitaux
finalement on a un peu l'impression que
cette crise sanitaire a mis en lumière
le malaise déjà existants dans l'hôpital
public
oui absolument la manière de voir la
crise son disciple tarentaise et qui on
revient à ce qui se passait avant soit
on dit donc si une loupe grossissante
qu'à montrer les défauts de l'hôpital la
gestion commerciale de l'hôpital sous
contrainte budgétaire l'avait emporté
sur le soin ceux qui étaient les patrons
absolue utiliser ce qu'on doit faire
comment on doit le faire c'était
gestionnaire très loin des soins là tout
d'un coup ils ont été incapables de
prendre les choses en main ce sont des
équipes soignantes qui ont réorganiser
complètement l'hôpital de même que avant
avoir 1 livid c'était inadmissible c'est
perdre de l'argent il fallait que le
taux d'occupation des histoires maximum
ce qui s'est d'ailleurs que les patients
qui devait être hospitalisé aux urgences
rester des heures à mesure sur les
brancards
alors là on était content d'avoir des
livres pour accueillir les malades
évidemment quand on fait les urgences il
faut avoir des lits vides en permanence
et c'est comme si vous disiez on paye
des pompiers que contient le feu il faut
il faut que les pompiers soient
organisées entraîné fort mais les bons a
vendu du feu pour pouvoir l'utiliser
efficacement alors c'est ça qu'on a vu
sur le paiement de type commercial
tarification on va inventer les tarifs
qu vidor le danger c'est de revoir tout
d'un coup tous ses appareils techno
gestionnaire vouloir reprendre en main
la logique antérieures le directeur de
la rs du grand test disait des classes
aisées fini on supprime 500 emplois à
nancy on ferme des lits le grand hôpital
nord c'est qu'ils fusionnent bichat et
beaujon à paris on 17 30% lui en moins
alors est ce que tout ça est revu est ce
qu'on dit les structures de gestion qui
servent à rien qu'ils ont montré lors
inutile dans la crise ou les supprimer
il faut garder ce qui est utile aux
soins et donc ça économisera d'ailleurs
du personnel
istres actif des réunions inutiles on a
vu l'efficacité d'un coup lorsque tout
le monde est concentré sur le champ
alors évidemment il y avait un côté
exceptionnel puisque avait plus qu'une
seule ma vie à l'hôpital
les soignants avaient pris la direction
de la restructuration de l'hôpital est
par ailleurs les gestionnaires c'était
leur service évidemment il n'y avait pas
de gaspillage un tout le monde était
mobilisé pour le juste choix pour les
patients pour essayer de sauver les
patients en étant assez économe sur tout
ce qu'on devait faire en raison de la
pénurie
donc voilà il faut tirer les leçons pour
dire il faut changer le prénom la
république l'a dit il à vie la santé
doit échapper aux lois du marché mais
très bien mais tirons en les conclusions
6 11 ans complètement les conclusions
ont depuis maintenant plus de dix ans on
s'est complètement trompé
on est parti sur ce que les directeurs
une fois l'hôpital de flux et un nokia
de stock et voilà on dit pareil sur les
matches on est pareil sur les
médicaments et on voit le résultat
la santé doit échapper aux lois du
marché la sécurité sanitaire doit passer
avant le profit voilà c'est pas possible
qu'on n'est pas le curé avant france
messieurs grimaldi merci d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur émérite de médecine à la
pitié salpêtrière et membre du collectif
en terre hôpitaux merci d'avoir est en
direct